welcome to Colombia fun is so exciting
and congratulations to the 39 faculty
students and alumni who have 25
submissions in this year's sundance film
festival we're proud of you
congratulations
we've got you about more and more with
Sundance over period of time we love the
mission of Sundance movies are something
to kind of take for granted we all go to
the movies but I've never actually spent
a lot of time thinking about how they're
crafted and here at Sundance I learned a
lot about that meaning the columbia
filmmakers i learned a lot about that
and it's actually to be honest with you
and I when I've some of the films are
seen as we went brain has been bursting
this is one of my favorite events of the
years I Columbia party at Sundance I
feel like every year I come out of it
seeing people that I haven't seen in a
long time but really meeting a lot of
connections and people that we have to
leave something in common and we have
they're looking out for me and I'm
looking out for them and this is it i
think really connects me and makes me
feel like i am again a part of a bigger
community
we brought our daughter and she had
applied for early admission and the year
that she was going to be entering
Columbia we brought her to this party so
it's a great way for her to learn about
one of the parts of Columbia everyone's
very friendly you know even though i'm
not in the film industry they really
want to talk about their films and their
experience and their connections to
columbia you know you know and they'll
tell you a lot about the industry and
it's really fun to kind of have a little
inside glimpse as to what they do it's
kind of like columbia comes to utah when
columbia decided to do this event here
in Park City Utah I could not have been
more excited I've been hopefully helpful
in facilitating different events
sponsoring different parties for the
filmmakers and just having more Columbia
people come to Utah and see what we have
here I got kind of a little mini course
in filmmaking by being here last year
and I had a great time being a Columbia
person made me feel like an insider here
at Sundance so I kind of made separately
set the times on my calendar for this
year that this year might get right
Colombia is like a community and it's
all about collaboration when you make
films your filmmaking is the art of
collaboration learning how to work with
people and and learning who you like to
work with and who who understands you
and who trusts you and who you trust and
and that's what Columbia was meeting all
these great friends and people that will
be working with forever in our career
i do feel i do feel emotionally and
intellectually connected with fondant
and i think I always will
you